how fast are you moving right now that
seems like an easy question
the first tempting answer is I'm not
moving upon further reflection you
realize that maybe the Earth's motion
counts so a second tempting answer is 19
miles per second around the Sun but then
you recall learning that the Sun moves
around the center of the Milky Way
galaxy and the Milky Way moves within
the local group of galaxies and the
local group moves within the Virgo
cluster and the Virgo cluster moves
within how fast are you moving is not an
easy question when Mission Control tells
astronauts how fast they're going
there is always an assumed standard of
rest at the start of the voyage speeds
are given relative to the launch pad but
later when the launch pad is just one
more arbitrary place down there on
Earth's spinnin surface speeds are given
relative to the idealized
Naughton spinning pinpoint center of
Earth on their way to the moon Apollo
astronauts had a hard time answering the
question how fast are you moving speed
away from Earth was one thing and speed
toward the moon was quite another that's
because the earth and the moon move
relative to one another
ah of course speed is a relative
quantity when Captain Kirk asks
lieutenant Sulu
if the Starship Enterprise has reached a
speed of warp 7 Sulu should reply
relative to what captain such a sassy
reply may get subordinate Starfleet
officers in trouble but it is the only
good answer to the question how fast are
you moving this is basic relativity
talking not fancy Einstein Ian's
relativity but good old-fashioned and
still correct Galilean relativity
Galileo seems to have been the first
person to realize that there is no such
thing as an absolute speed speeds are
relative this means that speeds only
have meaning when they are referred to a
reference frame presumably that
reference frame is itself at rest but
then we have to ask again at rest
relative to what because even the
concept of rest has lost any hint of
absolute meaning
being his relative and rest is relative
Earth's speed is 19 miles per second
relative to the Sun the enterprise's
speed is warp 7 relative to the center
of the Milky Way galaxy your speed is
zero relative to your easy chair but
depending on where you sit it is
hundreds of miles per hour relative to
Earth's center when we Pharrell brow and
ask but how fast is Earth really moving
we imagine spaceship earth plowing
through the ocean of space as it orbits
the Sun but space is not an ocean it has
no substance as water does space is not
a thing
space is nothing space is no thing you
can move between two points in space say
between Earth and Mars but you can't
move through space there's nothing to
move through it's like trying to say how
much a hole weighs a hole weighs exactly
nothing because a hole is nothing it's a
void and so is space to move relative to
nothing is meaningless the concepts of
speed and of rest have only relative
meaning they are absolutely meaningless
they mean something only with respect to
arbitrarily chosen artificial frames of
reference if someday you are buckled
into your spaceship and you see from the
side window say a space station whizzed
by at constant speed there is no way to
know which of you is really moving
neither of you is really moving because
there is no deep reality about constant
speed constant speed in a straight line
has only relative meaning a kind of
relative reality does this mean that all
motion is relative no some motions have
only relative meaning but some motions
have absolute meaning are absolutely
real
for example constant speed is relative
but change in speed is absolute calling
something absolute in science means that
arbitrary standards are not used in its
measurement it is unambiguously
measurable when your spaceship fires its
engines your change in speed is beyond
doubt you feel it in your stomach and
your ship sensors can measure it outside
your window the passing Space Station
may seem to be changing speed but the
beings inside the station
not feeling and no sensors can measure
it you are really changing speed and
they really are not there's something
absolutely real about changes in speed
the same goes for rotation if your
spaceship is spinning you can feel it
and your ship sensors can measure it the
space station outside may seem to be
going around you but it is you who feels
queasy not the folks in the space
station you are really spinning and they
really are not there's something
absolutely real about rotation so some
motions are relative and some are not
there is no deep reality about constant
speed but changes in speed are deeply
real and so are rotations we have to be
thoughtful in our analysis of everyday
experience in order to identify what is
deeply real since we can be fooled by
perceptions as basic as speed may be
every perception deserves careful
scrutiny this is what inspired line
Sunday's incredible insights about the
speed of light and forward time travel
knowing how to identify what is deeply
real is tough and important work
if a police officer ever pulls you over
for speeding and asks do you know how
fast you were going and insightful
though perhaps unwise reply would be
relative to what
and then as you sit in the back seat of
the police car and feel it accelerate
toward jail
you can add but some things are absolute
you